في مصر وعلى مدار اسبوع تتابع نشر الرسائل
مسربه لمعتقلين سياسيين في سجن بدر ثلاثه
او ما يسمى حكوميا بمركز الاصلاح والتاهيل
يقع بدر على بعد نحو 70 كيلومترا شرق
القاهره هذا السجن سجن بدر الذي افتتح
حديثا ويعرف بالعقرب الجديد لما ينسب
لادارته من انتهاكات بحق نزلائه السياسيين
احدى عنوان انقذوا معتقلي بدر ثلاثه من
الموت تحدثت الرساله المسربه الاولى
والمؤرخه في الاول من مارس الجاري عن
الحرمان من الزياره والتريض وعن الضغط على
المعتقلين المطالبين بتلك الحقوق ما حمل
عشرات منهم على محاوله الانتحار وتحت
عنوان مجاعه قاتله اشارت احدى الرسائل
لوقف صرف الادويه الدوريه للمرضى وقالت ان
اجمالي ما يقدم للنزيل الواحد من الطعام
يصل فقط 200 جرام يوميا وسلطه احدى
الرسائل الضوء على تجاهل اداره سجن بدر
ثلاثه لما قضت به لائحه السجون المصريه من
لم شم المعتقلين اذا كانوا اقارب من
الدرجه الاولى وقالت ان احد المعتقلين
اقدم على الانتحار كي يتمكن فقط من رؤيه
ابيه في مستشفى السجن ولكن دون جدوى
رساله اخرى ايضا تساءلت عن امكانيه تعرف
الاهالي على ذويهم المعتقلين ان التقوا
مجددا بعد سنوات من منع الزياره قبل ان
ينقلوا لبدر ثلاثه وما اصابهم في تلك
السنوات من شيب وهزال بسبب الحرمان المزمن
من الحقوق الاساسيه
على وقع تتابع تلك الرسائل وتسليط الضوء
عليها
اعلاميا سارعت وزاره الداخليه المصريه
بالنفي واتهمت في تغريده لها مقاله انها
ابواق اعلاميه تابعه لجماعه الاخوان
تحاول اثاره البلبله
السلطات المصريه تحاول اتخاذها خطوات في
ملف المعتقلين على وقع ضغوط حقوقيه طالت
لسنوات فغيرت مثلا اسم مصلحه السجون الى
قطاع الحمايه المجتمعيه وبات السجن يسمى
مركز اصلاح وتاهيل
خلال الفتره الماضيه شكلت لجان رسميه
للعفو عن المعتقلين وقد اتهمت بالتركيز
على تيارات سياسيه
واغفى لاخرى
الخطوات الرسميه لم تمنع تصاعد اعداد
وفيات الاهمال الطبي بين المعتقلين
السياسيين على مدار السنوات الماضيه والتي
وصلت منذ مطلع العام الجاري فقط الى 23
حلقه
في سياق متصل يقصر القانون المصري فتره
الحبس الاحتياطيه على عامين فقط بينما
تتحدث تقارير حقوقيه كثيره عن تجاوز اعداد
كبيره من المعتقلين السياسيين هذه المده
بسنوات ولكن دون محاك